the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let's go ahead and and get started
so tad is in California today so he
asked me to give today's lecture which
will be based on a research project that
we're working on at the DCI this is
actually really connected to
confidential transactions and
confidential assets which I think that
you guys covered in a previous class so
Peterson commitments will play a very
important role in the work I'm about to
present I want to present this work that
we've been doing this is joint work with
Willie Vasquez who was an MIT MN he
graduated and moved to UT Austin and
madara's versa who's a research
scientist with the DCI and this project
is called ZK ledger
it's about privacy-preserving auditing
for distributed Ledger's so to start
with I'm not sure how much work you guys
have done on permissioned blockchain and
so far how much have you covered with
respect to provision blockchains
nothing at all okay maybe we should
start with should we start with what is
a permission blockchain or do you guys
feel like you have a handle on what that
means or what that is it's most generic
abstract sense yes yeah so um good
question
okay so you know these words that we use
permissioned versus permissionless
usually refer to who has write access to
the chain so in crypto currencies like
Bitcoin and aetherium theoretically any
one of us could spin up our own ASIC get
really lucky - and put the transactions
that we are interested in into the chain
now of course no one's going to accept
that block if it violates sort of the
majority consensus rules of the chain
but assuming that it follows the rules
it's well formatted it's that it has the
appropriate proof of work etc any one of
us could submit a block to the Bitcoin
blockchain right there are there's no
permissions on who is allowed and who
isn't allowed to write to the Bitcoin
blockchain permissionless blockchain
sorry permissioned block chains are a
different story these are more like
disturbed
databases the idea behind permissioned
blockchains is that you choose a set of
actors ahead of time and only those
actors are allowed to write to the
blockchain so you can't just have anyone
willy-nilly spinning up a mining node or
spinning up a node in the system and
submitting transactions and things to
the blockchain usually permissioned
versus permissionless doesn't say
anything about reads and who can read
the blockchain we're really just talking
about rights so an important use there
you know permission blockchains i think
are not really the focus of this course
in part because we sort of take the
position that the technology behind them
are is essentially distributed databases
and there's lovely courses out there on
distributed databases and you know
there's a lot to learn about them and
they're very interesting but they're not
necessarily sort of very closely related
to cryptocurrencies and sort of the
designs of the past decade so so that's
the idea behind permission blockchains
now as I was saying I think that there's
a lot of use cases for permission block
chains they're very useful distributed
databases in general are very useful and
so let's talk about one of them and I'm
going to kind of interchangeably use
permissioned blockchain and distributed
ledger here distributed ledger
permission blockchain I'm kind of sort
of saying the same thing so let's start
with so permission block chains any
questions before we kind of dive into
the use case and z:k ledger about
permission block chains kind of get the
idea it's a whole bunch of people
working together to construct the ledger
so let's start with the structure of the
financial system and this is kind of
setting the use case for z:k ledger and
what we were trying to do and what we
were trying to address so to start with
there are dozens of very large
investment banks that are trading
securities currencies commodities
derivatives many of these things are
traded on exchanges regulated exchanges
legs like Nasdaq or the New York Stock
Exchange but up to 40% are actually
traded in unregulated fashion they're
done in a way that's called
over-the-counter meaning that there is
no regulated exchange sitting in the
middle facilitating these trades instead
the banks the entities trade amongst
themselves in sort of a slightly more ad
hoc fashion this represents trillions of
dollars of the economy and just to give
you a sense of scale sort of the time
frequency we're dealing with we're not
talking about high-frequency trading
that's not the use case that CK ledger
is targeting we're thinking like tens of
trades a minute these are things that
are that are done electronically it's
not like people are people might be
calling each other up to arrange these
trades but oftentimes they're done
electronically but we're not considering
high-frequency trading so a useful
abstraction of for thinking about you
know a table of these trades is a
transaction ledger so each row in the
ledger is a transaction transferring
assets from one bank to another so this
should be very familiar to everyone it
looks a little bit different than things
like Bitcoin because since this is a
sort of a ledger designed for the
existing financial system we know who
the entities are they have names they're
regulated there they're you know they
have companies behind them we're not
talking just about arbitrary public keys
so each row in the ledger is a
transaction so here Citibank is
transferring a million dollars so that's
another thing that's very different than
cryptocurrencies here we have multiple
different assets being recorded in the
ledger so we're not talking about a
ledger with a native asset necessarily
this is not a cryptocurrency really
think about this like a table in the
database recording transactions those
transactions might be in dollars or
Euros or municipal bonds or securities
or shares they could be anything right
so we're just kind of recording
transactions so Citibank is transferring
a million dollars to Goldman Sachs JP
Morgan is transferring money to UBS and
to Barclays okay so as with crypto
currencies I think crypto currencies
have kind of inspired people to
reconsider the case of a distributed
database as a ledger that multiple
entities can write to and one of what
part of that consideration involves
thinking about digital signatures so
maybe these banks have
of public private key pairs and perhaps
they use their keys to indicate consent
on the transaction right this is
something that's kind of done under the
hood right now when you think about the
protocols we use to exchange data but
it's not necessarily done explicitly
when conduct when creating these
distributed databases so they can use
their there are keys to attach
signatures to the transaction to
indicate a consent to transfer for
security
now this ledger might be maintained by a
third party or it could be a distribute
database of permissioned blockchain that
is run by the transacting parties so
there are some important financial
invariants that you want to maintain
here to verify that transactions are
happening correctly that you know that
the that they're valid that assets
aren't created out of nowhere so you
know one of them is consent to transfer
and we use these signatures for that
another important thing to verify
another important invariant is that the
person doing the transacting actually
has the assets to transfer that you know
they're not making up assets out of
nowhere or they're not double spending
that there isn't something incorrect
happening and then that assets are
neither created nor destroyed that we
have conservation of assets so these are
important financial invariants to
maintain this problem this looks a lot
like what you know the invariants are
that we're trying to maintain an ax
crypto currency like Bitcoin or
aetherium except this was with multiple
assets and we kind of know who the
people are involved now if this ledger
were being maintained by an exchange
then the exchange would be responsible
for kind of verifying and validating
that all of these transactions are
correct if this ledger is being
maintained by the participants it's a
permission blockchain then you know
everyone can verify and validate that
these invariants are being maintained by
looking at the blockchain by checking
the signatures right so that's great
except for the fact that privacy is
really really important and quite a bit
of data and quite a bit of sensitive
information is actually leaked by
looking at these transactions so if we
want to be able to maintain financial
invariants if we want to be able to
check and make sure that the ledgers
correct and I mean this is sort of the
whole point of blockchains is that
everyone can sort of verify and validate
and reconcile you know real-time then in
the act of looking at those transactions
you're actually finding out really
sensitive information about banks
trading strategy about their
intellectual property okay for example a
large trade might indicate that a bank
has decided to get out of a position
other banks can learn about this notice
it on the blockchain as they're
validating transactions and try to
follow suit driving down the price so
privacy especially in this type of
context is really important and I'm sure
you can imagine a lot of other different
types of contexts in which privacy is
important as well right so we don't want
to be in this situation where we have to
choose between privacy and being able to
validate what's going on right so even
if we were to use a trusted third party
like an exchange we still wouldn't have
privacy necessarily because the exchange
would be looking at everything in the
ledger so that's sort of the goal here
that we're trying to achieve we're
trying to achieve this goal where we
want to be able to publicly verify and
validate what's happening in the ledger
and at the same time obtain some amount
of privacy for transactions we don't
want all transactions to be public to
whoever is maintaining the ledger be
that a third party exchange or a set of
banks so I'm just gonna pause right
there and and sort of you know do we
kind of get this set up here privacy
versus verification we want both any
questions about that yes
yeah that's a great question so I'm you
know I I have dollars and euros here
right how do you know that Citibank
actually has those dollars to transfer
to goldman sachs right where does that
come from notice how this is transaction
number ninety i'm assuming that there's
a transaction up here this is just a
subset of the ledger but as you'll see
in a moment we we think about this role
of depositors who are allowed to deposit
assets into the ledger and so i'm
assuming there's a transaction up here
somewhere which in a sort of [ __ ] like
provable way shows that someone we trust
to deposit assets into the ledger gave
citibank the dollars necessary for them
to give to goldman sachs but you're
absolutely right if the asset isn't
native to the ledger then you are you do
have that connection to the real world
where you do need to apply some level of
trust the question is it is it auditable
can you at least track it back up to
that point
any other questions okay great so um so
we want to do the following we want to
be able to verify that financial
invariants are maintained that things
are correct while achieving privacy so
one good technique for achieving privacy
is simply to encrypt or hide the
transactions in the ledger
okay so surprisingly maybe we actually
know how to do this and to at the same
time still achieve checking of the
financial invariants here are two
systems that actually achieve this the
first is zero cash which was implemented
inside of Z cash an anonymous
cryptocurrency in Z cash transactions
are sort of very they're completely
hidden they're completely opaque
shielded transactions in C cash G cash
has two trains of transactions one set
is public like in Bitcoin the other set
it are called shielded transactions and
in a shielded transaction you don't know
who the parties are who involved are
involved you don't know the amount of
the asset that's transferred you
you can validate that that this was
correct that money you know financial
Marian's were maintained zero cash and Z
cash use a primitive called zero
knowledge proof and in particular ZK
snarks zero knowledge succinct arguments
of knowledge those were actually
developed in part here at MIT so so
using these sort of like really
interesting cryptographic primitives you
know we're able to maintain financial
invariants in Z cash there's another
system called solidus which is out of
Cornell which also achieves this you
can't tell who the participants are and
you you can still maintain financial
invariants solidus uses a completely
different cryptographic primitive called
PV ORM so you should check out what
these papers if you're interested it's
definitely still possible to do this to
do this to accomplish this right however
there's still a problem here both of
these systems hide everything you get no
insight into the economy into the
blockchain into what's actually
happening in the system regulators in
particular need insight into markets in
order to maintain financial stability
and in order to protect investors even
considering non-financial use cases it's
oftentimes the case that people who
might be using a blockchain or
distributed ledger distributed database
want to be able to to maintain that
certain things are true and to get some
insight into the system that they are
that they are that they're a part of
lack of insight can actually have
devastating effects as we saw with toxic
assets in 2008 one you know part of the
problem one contributor to the crisis
was the issue that people didn't really
have confidence or insight into exactly
what assets banks had on their books it
was a bit confusing and surprisingly
this happens to this day I think there
was a case with
with Dow Chemical where they didn't
actually know how many outstanding
shares that they had issued like they
just didn't know and then um they had to
they had to give out a dividend and they
would they just were like they gave out
too much money or too little money or
something like that so here are some
examples of things that we might want to
measure and understand we might want to
get a sense of leverage in the system so
what you know the participants who are
holding assets like how much do they
have on mass we might want to understand
exposure we might want to get a sense of
market concentration you know it's
pretty useful to know things like okay
this Bank like this asset in particular
is very highly concentrated or this
asset is more distributed amongst the
participants of the system so there are
things that we we might want to learn
about the economy represented by the
assets in the blockchain and that if the
entire thing is sort of encrypted or
completely opaque we're not going to be
able to really gain this insight and
toxic assets like I said so here's a
specific example of something we might
want to learn you know here's a bank
here's an auditor and the auditor might
want to and let's assume the bank is
using a system like ZK ledger provision
blockchain and auditor might want to
know how exposed is this bank to a drop
in the euro so if the you know the euro
versus the dollar changes dramatically
what's gonna happen to this banks
balance sheet so nzk ledger the auditor
can ask a question like what fraction of
your assets are in euros and the bank
might respond three million out of 100
million so you know three million euros
1 million dollars something like that
but you know just simply asking this
question the auditor doesn't really get
any any sort of assurance that this
answer is correct and so this is sort of
the Nugget of the problem that we are
trying to solve and achieve
so this talk presents the UK ledger and
it's an a private auditable transaction
ledger
the idea behind ZK ledger is like other
systems we also hide the transacting
banks and the amounts involved
we provide integrity with public
verification so despite the fact that
you can't really see the details of the
transaction anyone not just the
participants but anyone you want to sort
of show this to can publicly verify and
convince themselves that transactions
are well-formed and financial very
invariants are maintained and an auditor
can interactively compute provably
correct linear functions over the
transactions so things like trying to
understand market concentration or
leverage or exposure they can compute
sort of a set of queries over the
contents of the transactions in the
ledger okay so I'm going to describe to
you how zk legit works I'm going to sort
of give you a brief overview of the
system model and then I'm gonna start to
go into some of these sort of more
interesting pieces inside ZK ledger so
the commitments that we use to hide
things sort of the the way the ledger is
constructed and I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the primitives that we
use which are zero knowledge proof not
snarks which I talked about earlier a
different type is your knowledge proof
but I'll give you sort of a little bit
of a flavor of what those things look
like and then I'll show you sort of the
performance of ZK ledger so you know
whether you buy this use case or not I
think that you'll see these topics come
up over and over again as you're looking
at crypto currencies people are quite
interested in zero knowledge proof and
how they can use them to provide privacy
inside of crypto currencies so okay
Before we jump into the system model any
questions okay let's go so let's start
with the system model so here's the
system model we have a set of banks
these banks have generated public keys
and secret keys which they have and
these banks are working together to
construct a ledger and the way that this
ledger works is that they are
determining transactions amongst
themselves so they're deciding okay
you know I'm gonna transfer this amount
to that Bank and then once they've sort
of decided on a transaction they append
that trend
action to the ledger and again remember
this ledger could be maintained by a
third party it could be maintained by
the banks themselves in a blockchain
they could be using a public bulletin
board they could be posting transactions
to Twitter it doesn't matter we're not
sort of really concerned about that
right now
the point is that there is a n
append-only ledger and that's sort of
orthogonal to sort of our techniques how
exactly it's maintained an auditor a
third party auditor can obtain correct
answers to questions based on ledger
contents so note that auditing is
interactive it's not the case that
someone can just take this ledger and
compute things over it they can't do
that but there's not there's not enough
information here to reveal the answers
to queries the auditor has to actually
talk to the participants in the ledger
so you might say well we didn't trust
the participants to give the audit or
the right answer why would we trust them
to answer the auditor at all well kind
of in the setting that we've set up for
ourselves if they don't answer the
auditor they can go to jail okay so at
least you know you can tell whether the
bank is answering you or not if the bank
were to lie to you you might not be able
to tell whether or not you know this
allows you to be able to if you get an
answer you know that that answer is
correct
so the auditor will query the bank and
ask a question similar to what we were
asking before what fraction of your
assets are neros the bank can respond
but this time instead of just getting an
answer the auditor also gets a small
part of a proof from the bank and can
confirm that that proof is correct
based on these opaque transaction
details in the ledger okay so the
auditor still needs to to talk to the
bank but using the bank's response they
can compute a proof that shows that this
answer must be correct
okay so auditing is interactive like I
said it's possible bank might choose not
to respond that could happen also I want
to point out that if the auditor is
constantly auditing this ledger it's
constantly asking how many euros do you
have how many euros do you have how many
euros do you have then if that number
changes it's reasonable to assume that
that change happened in the last
transaction appended to the ledger right
so
you know if the if the bank continually
answers the auditors questions this will
leak transaction contents this doesn't
provide what's known as differential
privacy okay and so kind of the setup
here is that the auditor and the and the
bank should come to some agreement about
the appropriate level of sort of
frequency of auditing such that both the
auditor gets the data that they need and
the bank maintains the privacy that it
needs to maintain okay so as I said
before ZK ledger supports any linear
function over transaction values so we
can do ratios sums averages variants Q's
outliers by outliers I mean you know
give me all the transactions that have
amounts outside of this range so you
want all high value transactions you can
provably correctly give that
approximation so orders of magnitude of
my trades without revealing for the
precise number changes over time and
also well-known financial risk
measurements like the her fin doll
Hirshman index so in this talk oh sorry
yeah there are small amounts of well
defined leakage for some of these
measurements and we're sort of so for
example in order to compute the average
we actually compute the sum and the
number of transactions so we leak a
little bit more information than just
the average but but it's very
well-defined and in this talk I'm only
really going to talk about sums but but
our paper which I'll sort of put a
pointer to on the website explains how
to do more complex things and and
everything sort of built on the sums
primitive so let's sort of talk about
the security goals so what are we trying
to achieve with the system so first of
all we're trying to achieve privacy we
want to make sure that the auditor and
non-involved parties cannot see
transaction participants or amounts so I
don't know if I made this clear before
but it's not just the case that this
third party auditor can't see who's in
transactions or who's you know what
they're transacting anyone who's not
actually involved in the transact
and receiving or sending assets also
can't see inside of a transaction
completeness so what do we mean by
completeness what we mean by that is
that banks can't lie to the auditor you
know they can't say that they have five
million euros when actually they have
three million euros but also the bank
can't selectively leave out things okay
so you could imagine some ways of
constructing this in which if a bank was
really clever they could just sort of
not include some of the transactions
that they had received and thus change
their answers to the auditor but one of
our security goals that we achieve is
that it's impossible for a bank to omit
transactions when responding to the
auditor we also are looking to achieve
integrity so banks can't violate
financial invariants we assume that
banks are malicious but honest banks
should always be able to convince the
auditor of a correct answer so we don't
want to have a situation where a
malicious bank screws up the ledger such
that an honest bank can't respond to the
auditor because the ledger doesn't make
sense so we also want to maintain that
and then progress we also want to make
sure that a malicious bank can't block
other banks from transacting that they
can't hold up the entire ledger and I
think as sort of I described the design
it will become clear why these things
were issues that we were worried about
and it's part of sort of how we design
the system to address these problems so
the threat model and the the threat
model describes sort of what kind of
attacks that we are trying to protect
against and what kind of attacks we
don't protect against so banks might
attempt to steal or hide assets
manipulate balances or lie to the
auditor banks can arbitrarily collude so
they can try to work together to do
these things and banks or the auditor
might try to learn transaction contents
so we you know it's not that they're
passive they might actually be trying to
actively learn what's happening in the
ledger what's out of scope for this work
is a ledger that emits transactions or
is unavailable as I said we're agnostic
to the ledger implementation as long as
it's available so it accepts
transactions it doesn't if the ledger
doesn't accept transactions we can't we
can't help we can't provide our goals we
also don't protect against an adversary
who might be watching network traffic so
if you know there's an adversary whose
adversary was snooping on the network
and sees that two banks are
communicating a lot it's reasonable to
assume that those two banks are involved
in all the transactions there are other
techniques to deal with these problems
and then also what's out of scope is
banks leaking their own transactions if
a bank week their own transactions we
throw up our hands sorry we tried to
give you privacy but yeah okay so that's
the system model for ZK Ledger's that's
the threat model those are our goals
that's what we're trying to achieve now
let's get into the design a little bit
so we're gonna build up the design based
on this example so here is an example of
a public transaction ledger and we're
going to slowly start to mask things in
this ledger until we sort of end up with
ZK Ledger's design so we have four
transaction he four transactions here
I'm only using one asset euros you'll
notice that the first transaction
addresses the question that you asked
which is well where do funds come from
and here we have sort of a special
depositor who is injecting assets into
the system this depositor might be the
central bank for example a lot of
systems are actually designed this way
so stellar I think chains blockchain
ripple you know these systems are all
designed with the idea of a special
depositor who's allowed to create their
own asset and insert it into the system
so here maybe the depositor is the
european central bank maybe it's some
other Bank who provably has a lot of
euros in their account and puts them
onto the ledger so there's a depositor
who's granting 30 million euros to
goldman sachs and then there are three
transactions and it's i think it's
important to sort of like get a sense of
what these transactions are so goldman
sachs is transferring ten million to
JPMorgan and then JPMorgan in
two different transactions is
transferring money to Barclays okay so
let's sort of move on from here so like
I said the depositor injects assets the
ledger and that's the way of entering
transactions
that's the depositor right there
now our goals are to achieve auditing
and privacy what do we mean by that well
we shouldn't look at someone looking at
the ledger shouldn't be able to tell
these amounts except for the depositor
transaction which is always public in
z.k laser to the depositor transactions
are public but they shouldn't be able to
tell from after that that Goldman Sachs
gave money to JP Morgan and that JP
Morgan gave it to Barclays and what the
amounts were okay so in this example
we're going to try to provably audit
Barclays to figure out how many euros
Barclays is holding and again we want to
hide the participants amounts and the
transaction graph so what is it what do
I mean when I say transaction graph I
think you guys learned a little bit
about a system called confidential
transactions a few weeks ago
confidential transactions does not hide
the transaction graph it hides the
amounts but you can tell sort of the
source of the funds so here the money
that Barclays got so if if we were
trying to sort of attain privacy in the
system the fact the goldman sachs got
euros and goldman sachs is the only
company that got euros is public because
depositor transactions are public but we
shouldn't be able to tell that the euros
that Barclays got obviously they must
have been sourced through goldman sachs
we shouldn't be able to tell they went
through anyone or how many people they
went through or that it was JP Morgan so
if we leaked the transaction graph you
might be able to tell that there was an
entity that the money went through
before it got to Barclays so when we say
we want to hide the transaction graph
that's what we mean we want to be able
to hide sort of the flow of funds how
they move through the system okay
we hide the amounts by using a
cryptographic primitive called Peterson
commitments so Peterson commitments as
you learned are binding and hiding
commitments to a value and the way that
they work and I'm terribly sorry but I
use slightly different notation than tag
so tad uses additive notation and a
multiplicative notation and I use
exponential notation these mean exactly
the same thing I will very quickly sort
of like write down word what they are
so in taja's notation G and H are
generators in some group and if you have
some value and some randomness then you
would write a Peterson commitment as as
that okay
now whether it's R times G or V times H
isn't important the point is these are
two generators of a group in this case
don't looked at curve group and in
Bitcoin SEC P 256 K 1 it doesn't really
matter what those generators are you
just pick any two you could call this G
1 and G 2 if you wanted to and so this
is the way that that Tad's would write
it the way that I write it and I'm sorry
about this but it's good that you guys
get exposed to both ways because you'll
find both ways in the literature is in
exponential notation so I would write G
to the V H to the R and they're
multiplied together instead of added
together ok so this is just a purely a
notational thing it's just instead of
the multiply operator here we're doing
exponentiation instead of the plus
operator here we're doing multiplication
so Peterson commitment the way that you
commit to a value V is everyone has
chosen these generators the generator
choice is system-wide this isn't
something you pick at the time you make
a transaction the generator choice the
system-wide however the are the
randomness you do choose fresh each time
you pick a new randomness each time
and the way that you commit to a value
is by producing this value right here
which is the generator raised to the
value times the second generator raised
to the randomness and what this serves
to do is it's binding it's very
difficult to come up with later a
different V and a different R that ends
up equaling the same commitment and part
of that is based on an assumption called
the discrete logarithm the hardness of
the discrete logarithm problem and also
importantly these things can be
homomorphic ly combined so if we have
these commitments to these different
values and we multiply them together
well when you multiply things that are
raised to an exponent you end up adding
the exponent right so by multiplying
these things together we end up with a
valid commitment to the sum of the
values in the individual commitments
that we multiplied together so we can
homomorphic ly combine the commitments
it ends up summing in the expo and the
exponent and we end up with a valid
commitment to to the sum of the values
another nice property of Peterson
commitments is that they are very fast
to create combined and verify and
perhaps surprisingly we can actually
achieve all of the auditing functions
that I showed you earlier just using
Peterson commitments so before we move
on questions on Peterson commitments I
know that you guys learned about this in
a previous class but they're pretty
important they're used in a sort of I
mean they're used in confidential
transactions as well to prove that the
sum of the outputs is less than or equal
to the sum of the inputs if you guys
recall that so any questions
ah great question you're making this
commitment at the time that the
transaction is created and I'll get into
the details of who creates the
transaction and and what do they choose
and how does that happen and how do we
make sure they don't screw it up well so
measurements happen on top of the ledger
so we can actually do all of our
measurements basically just on those
commitments we don't have to add
anything to the ledger
okay so yes like I said we can achieve
all the auditing functions with Pearson
commitments and I'll go into a little
bit of detail okay great so we can use
Pearson commitments to hide the values
so again by using these commitments
you can't looking at this right here if
you don't know our you can't guess you
if you don't know var you you can't if
you don't know or you can't get guess
what V is that it could be anything so
so that's what we mean when we say that
that these commitments are perfectly
hiding so we also want to hide the
participants in the transaction
obviously and we're gonna do that using
other techniques just sort of hold that
in your head for a moment we're going to
jump to that but first quickly let's
take a look at how auditing might work
given that we're using these Peterson
commitments okay so assume that we have
hidden who the participants are in this
ledger through a technique that I'm not
telling you about yet we're hiding the
values in the transactions that are not
inject not these special transactions
that are injecting assets or removing
assets but just the transfers we're
hiding the values using Peterson
commitments okay so let's look at how
auditing might work so an auditor will
ask the bank in this case it's Barclays
so remember Barclays received euros and
two different transactions and should
tell the auditor three million the
auditor asks Barclays how many euros you
hold Barclays can convince the auditor
that three million is the right answer
by doing the following okay
Barclays can say hey auditor it's three
million okay
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
actually open up the combined
commitments for my transactions so I
don't actually have this on a slide here
but I will sort of write out what this
means okay
so we have two transactions here and two
commitments and one of them is G to the
1 million h2 though let's just say r1
and then the other is G to the 2 million
H to the r2 okay these are the
commitments in the ledger
Barkley's wants to convince the auditor
that it has three million euros it does
so but when you multiply these two
things together and the auditor can't
see what these two things are but this
is or actually I think it's calm calm
two three okay calm three times calm or
then when you multiply these two things
together you get g to the 1 million plus
2 million H to the r1 plus r2 okay this
is three million if barclays gives the
auditor three million and r1 plus r2 the
sum then the auditor can confirm that if
they raise G to this and H to this that
it's equal to the multiplication of the
two commitments on the ledger and the
auditor can given that these two things
are equal then the auditor knows that
the bank in fact did commit to two
commitments that sum to three million
dollars it doesn't know if that was one
point five and one point five or you
know one and two million nine hundred
9 it doesn't know what those individual
values were it just knows that the sum
is correct so questions about opening
commitments yes yeah those are sort of
three and four sorry I'm using different
numbers there are one in r2 but the comp
three income for our this is literally a
elliptic curve point so this is the
point is is posted to the ledger yes it
would yes and we will talk about how we
address that and r1 plus r2
yes and those two pieces of information
are enough to convince the auditor that
three million does in fact correspond to
the commitments on the ledger yes
sorry you the the auditor will get
[Music]
number of transactions in this straw man
example that I've done it does look that
way yes I'm gonna build up to how the
auditor won't know the number of
transactions did you have a question
you're responsible for tracking your
randomness and you're responsible for
tracking you know your own individual
details you have to keep that in your
own databases yes if someone found your
randomness is then they could guess they
could sort of backwards compute the
values of your transactions yes okay the
time getting to that so we'll get to
that so kind of just sort of in figures
showing what we did there the auditor
can look at those two commitments
compute the product for themselves and
confirm that this three million lines up
with what they see however this has the
problem that it reveals the transactions
in which Barclays was involved right
Barclays is saying hey multiply these
two things together right and not only
that Barclays could lie okay
Barclays could say oh actually I only
have 1 million euros here's the
transaction that proves that I have 1
million euros I will just give you R 1 I
will just point to this transaction
don't worry about the other transactions
I'm not involved in them the the the
bank Barclays could leave out relevant
important transactions and sort of this
straw man design okay
the and and importantly this would match
up right the auditor would say okay
you've given me the you know Barclays
could just give could leave this part
out entirely could just give 1 million
and r1
and the auditor would say well yes that
does match up to commitment three great
good work and they wouldn't even know
that there was another commitment out
there that they should be concerned
about so how do we address this problem
and this I think was like the key
insight in the design of our system in
ZK Ledger a transaction actually has a
commitment for every participant in the
system so let's talk about that for a
second
so depositor transactions still
basically look the way that they did
before they're public but transfer
transactions now look quite different we
don't actually have the names of the
participant in the transaction the names
are implied by the values of the
commitments in that participants column
so now we're kind of looking at a
transaction as a row with multiple
columns and each there's a column per
participant in the system if a bank is
not involved in the transaction at all
then their commitment is to the value
zero if the bank is involved in a
transaction and it's doing the spending
then its value sorry depositor
transactions yes if the bank is involved
in the transaction it's doing the
spending it commits to a negative value
and if it's doing the receiving it
commits sorry not it but the creator of
the transaction commits to a positive
value so the way that you transfer one
million dollars from one bank to another
is committing to a negative value in the
spenders column here at JP Morgan and
committing to a positive value in the
receiver's column here Barclays
and again for non-involved banks entries
commit to zero but one thing I want to
stress commitments to zero are
completely indistinguishable from
commitments to any other value and
commitments to negative values are
indistinguishable from commitments to
positive values so someone looking at
this just looking at these commitments
posted to the ledger has no idea which
ones are zeros and which ones are
negative and which ones are positive yes
great question so yeah one design might
have it be the case that every black
bank actually has to be involved in
every transaction we managed to design
ZK ledger so that the spending bank can
produce one of these without actually
involving any of the other banks and I
will describe how that happens
okay and so given now that we've said
essentially every bank is involved in
every transaction this actually makes
life easier for the auditor because now
when the auditor audits a bank they
audit every transaction so they audit
the entire column for a bank so here
when the auditor is auditing Barclays
they won't just look at whatever
transactions Barclays tells them to look
at they will look at every transaction
okay and this is where I think someone
asked about timing or you know how do
you audit sort of like a range of
transactions the auditor can actually
tell the bank oh I just want to audit
from this point onwards or you know it
can say I just want to audit your
transactions for the past month right if
it wants to that doesn't mean that
Barclays can leave out transactions
because the time there's also a time
there's supposed to be a timestamp
column in here as well so you can see
when transactions happen that's public
so what happens here is the auditor is
going to look at everything they're
actually going to multiply three
commitments together because there's
three commitments in that column and it
doesn't know which ones are zero and
which ones are not zero but the zero
doesn't contribute to the sum and so a
malicious bank can't actually lied the
auditor because in this case the bank is
not going to leave out commitment for
and in fact it's also going to include
commitment to
so the audit the the the bank is going
to have to sort of include are the are
primes in here to get all of this to
work out correctly it's gonna have to
include everything so this next I'm
actually going to skip a little bit of
this because I think we're running a bit
low on time and I do want to get into
what the proofs look like so I'm going
to skip this averages part I'm going to
go back to our security goals what I
just described to you the sort of ledger
table construction allows us to achieve
our first two security goals privacy
because these commitments are perfectly
hiding
no one can see transaction participants
they can't tell who's committing to zero
and who's not committing to zero banks
can't lie to the auditor because the
auditor audits every transaction for a
bank but what I haven't sort of figured
out yet is well how do we maintain
financial invariants in this scheme how
do we make sure assets are created out
of nowhere how do we make sure that um
that whoever spending actually consented
to the spend and how do we construct
this transaction that involves every
bank when we assume banks are malicious
and we don't want one bank to be able to
hold up everyone from transacting so our
solution to do that is to use a set of
what are called music's non interactive
zero knowledge proof so what our music
music SAR short binary strings true
statements have proofs so if a statement
is true it should have a proof
indicating that it's true false
statements only have proofs with
negligible probability and proofs don't
reveal why they are true
so we're going to use musics to prove
things like the person who knows the
secret key for this public key consented
to this transfer without indicating
which bank it was that consented to the
transfer we're going to use in is
extinct
this Bank has the assets to spend
without revealing how many assets that
Bank actually has so ZK ledger uses a
set of carefully crafted mythix and to
be clear NICs are pretty old there you
know invented in like the 80s and the
90s and most of them are based on the
hardness of the discrete log problem in
elliptic curve cryptography again so
here are sort of the properties we want
to achieve with transactions we want
transaction validity we want to make
sure whoever is the spender who have
whoever has a negative amount in their
column actually consented to the
transfer and again remember in crypto
currencies and things like that where
it's okay to reveal who the person is
who's spending we use a signature in
this case we'll use proof of knowledge
of secret key so there's a consent music
we want to we want to be able to prove
that whoever spending actually has the
assets to transfer that they're not
going negative and we use an assets
music and we want to make sure that
assets are neither created or destroyed
and created nor destroyed so for that we
use a balance mystic we want to show
that you know things work out and you
didn't create more euros than you were
supposed to the only place where you can
do that is in the depositor transactions
the public deposit or transactions we
also want to make sure that honest banks
can make progress and in order to do
that creating a transaction in ZK ledger
is non-interactive the banks don't have
to interact to create a ledger to create
a transaction this is exactly how
systems like aetherium and Bitcoin work
if you think about it I can't stop you
from sending me Bitcoin right if you
want to send me Bitcoin you construct a
transaction that sends me Bitcoin you
submit it to the blockchain I have
nothing to do with that offline we might
have agreed that the reason you're
sending me but
because I'm selling you my car or
something like that but to actually
create the transaction that spends you
don't have to talk to the other
participants and we use a a consistency
music so that the person creating the
transaction can prove in a publicly
verifiable way that everything matches
up correctly that all of these proofs
are correct and that all of the banks
are going to be able to later respond to
the auditor be able to respond to the
auditor as necessary so to give you a
little bit of insight into why this
consistency music is necessary over here
I was speaking as though the bank knew
all of the are values right
actually in ZK ledger if a bank is not
involved in a transaction if their
commitments to zero they don't know
their own R value because some other
bank has created that so if we kind of
go backwards a little bit to hear
Barclays wasn't involved in this
transaction at all and in fact Barclays
so Goldman Sachs created this
transaction JP Morgan created this one
and this one Barclays had nothing to do
with them they weren't involved at all
and we can't assume that Barclays knows
what the ours are in its column yet the
way that I told you that Barclays
responds to the auditor is by revealing
the sum of the ours so that's actually
not how Zeek a ledger works they don't
actually reveal to some of the ARS the
proof is a little bit as a little bit
more complicated they were they these
some of the ARS are encoded for Barclays
in a way that it can't see what they are
but it can use them and the consistency
proof is to prove that that encoding was
done correctly so again you can see the
paper for details but I'm actually gonna
tell you a little bit about these proofs
and what they look like
okay so consent
the consent proof is proof of knowledge
of secret key SK so what this means is
that if the value in the commitment in
this entry is negative then there should
be a proof of knowledge of secret key to
indicate that this Bank has consented to
subtracting from their assets also if
the value is negative you need to create
a proof of assets technically you don't
need a proof of assets if the value is
not negative but we're trying not to
reveal remember which bank is involved
in which transaction so I'm going to
draw a transaction up here and kind of
explain a little bit about where these
proofs actually go so a transaction is a
row and there is an entry for each bank
in the transaction so there is a
commitment so let's let some negative 1
million
and then there is also these sets of
proofs so proof of assets in particular
and every single entry has a proof of
assets even though really this is the
only bank that's spending and needs to
prove that it has assets the proof of
assets is constructed to look like this
it's a new commitment either to the some
of the values in the column or if you're
not the spending bank a some a
commitment to the value and it also
includes a proof that the value in this
sort of auxilary commitment is in range
so what do i mean by that when we're and
i think you guys should have covered
this in the Petersons commitment lecture
with confidential transactions but when
you're dealing with cyclic groups you
can wrap around the end of the group and
that's sort of the same as if you hadn't
wrapped around there are many different
sort of things that can occupy one point
in the space of a cyclic group so we
need to include proofs that you're not
that your value is in a range that's
expected and in the case of Zeke a
ledger we need to prove that the values
between zero and a certain upper limit
that is less than the order of the group
and we use a technique we use the exact
same technique that they use in
confidential transactions to do this
Borromean rings signatures what's kind
of exciting is that a few months ago
there was some work done on a faster
smaller more aggregate able version of
range proofs using a system called
bulletproof s-- so as you'll see in the
in the evaluation this sounds like such
a silly little thing oh yeah also prove
that the values in range this is like
ninety percent of all of the space and
work in z:k ledger these range proofs
are like the bane of our existence they
take up a lot of space they're very slow
to create and verify but they're
necessary so making them faster is a
really amazing thing
then the next thing is balance and I
think this one is illustrative because
it shows that a proof sometimes you have
a proof not by creating an additional
binary string but by the way you choose
things in your transaction so the way
that you prove that no funds are created
or destroyed is as follows so these are
remember these commitments are G to the
zero let's say H star one G to the
negative 1 million H to the R 2 and G to
the 1 million H to the R 3 now given
that we have these commitments how can
we prove to someone that no assets were
created or destroyed well what does it
mean for no assets to be created or
destroyed it means that the sum of the
V's is equal to zero right that's what
it means for no assets to be created or
destroyed how can we prove to someone
that given that all they're seeing are
these commitments that the sum of the
V's commit to zero well let's just make
the sum of the ARS
also commit to zero so if these some of
the ARS also commits to zero then when
you multiply these things together
you're gonna get G to the sum of the v's
H to the sum of the ARS and if both of
these things are zero you get G to 0 H
to the zero which should equal what one
exactly
so we construct we choose our R's very
carefully so that the auditor or
whoever's verifying this can just
multiply all the commitments together
and verify that they equal one and if it
equals one that means it would have been
very difficult to choose v's such that
you could make this come out to one
without it actually coming out to one so
that's the proof of balance it's not an
actual proof it's not a short binary
string it's literally choosing the
exponents in a clever way to show that
we can maintain the invariant that we
want does that make sense
questions about these proofs and I
didn't go into proof of assets very much
it's the most complicated one but you
can check out the paper see some
confused faces you don't have to ask
about the proofs in a certain way and
then choose well we're trying to prove
that the payment sum to zero that's what
we want because that means that assets
weren't created or destroyed and
remember then everyone okay so this is
an important so basically what you're
saying I think what you're saying okay
you could be saying one of two things
number one what if you choose your
reason are such that it doesn't sum to
zero right what if you produce an
invalid transaction and the answer is
that everyone will reject it sort of
similar to Bitcoin if you don't have a
valid transaction good for you but you
know it's gonna be considered invalid by
everyone in the system
everyone's gonna skip it and ignore it
it's not going to be a part of what
happens right so this is part of the
proof of validity that all of the
participants have consented to the
second question you might be asking is
what if the sum what if these don't sum
to zero but I still managed to figure
out how to make how to make this equal
one right that's what you okay so that's
the question you're asking based on the
assumption that the discrete logarithm
problem is hard this is this is like
this is too hard to figure out you
literally cannot find you there's an
assumption here that these are two
generators of the group right so that
means the G is equal to H to the X that
there's some way to produce one
generator from the other generator
there's an assumption here that figuring
out what that X is is nearly impossible
so you don't know what G is
in terms of H and given that you don't
know this relationship between G and H
you can't figure out you can't figure
out how to produce two exponents that
sum to what you want them to some do so
this is the this is the hardness problem
that these that these systems are based
on if you could do that if you could
figure out a R's such that it gave you
you know a 1 with the V Z wanted then
you would have broken the discrete log
problem yes great question so the answer
is that in our system the way that we
choose G and H is by taking the sha-256
hash of 0 and 1 and you can that those
are those are numbers such that the you
know they're sufficiently sort of random
and they show that that you know if
every one you know you just you took a
hash of 0 and 1 and how'd it like what
it you know have no relationship between
those two and everyone uses the same G
and H right from the beginning any other
questions
okay so we're kind of running low on
time but I do want to go through the
evaluation really quickly because um so
this system this paper was presented at
n s di in April which is a systems
conference and I think part of the
reason that the systems community liked
it was because it's surprisingly fast
you know you might have heard that
computing on encrypted data is too slow
it's infeasible you can't do it well the
answer is actually if you understand the
set of computations you want to do
really well you can structure things
using things like these musics and the
discrete log problem in such a way that
you can do that set of computation
actually pretty fast so so ZK ledger is
written in go
it uses an elliptic curve as the group P
256 K 1 which is the same elliptic curve
that Bitcoin uses we use range proofs to
prevent overflow like I said we used to
say
as in confidential transactions and
confidential assets and it's around
4,000 lines of code
it's mostly cryptography functions we
don't actually implement our own ledger
because we're ledger agnostic so in the
evaluation we want to understand how
fast is auditing first of all right and
then second you know the construction I
described to you you might think is very
slow because every bank has an entry in
every transaction so how does this
actually work in practice can we can we
get away with such a construction so
first let's talk about the auditing a
learning is really fast so here we're
auditing for banks and we're doing a
measurement called the her friend all
Hirshman index so we're trying to
understand market concentration for a
given asset and what's happening here is
the auditor is kind of keeping up with
the ledger and keeping these things that
we call commitment caches so because of
the design of our system and the fact
that we're using these Peterson
commitments which we can actually sort
of maintain rolling sums going down of
these commitments and use them when
needing to answer the auditor or confirm
that a bank has the correct answer and
so this means that auditing for banks is
milliseconds it's a few milliseconds to
audit the banks and you know we see here
on the x-axis we have the number of
transactions in the ledger the reason
that auditing a bank is independent of
the number of transactions in the ledger
is because of these commitment caches we
can do it really fast
assuming an online auditor who's kind of
keeping up with things we um yeah and
part of the reason for that is because
of our design it's very amenable to
caching now if the auditor is not online
and hasn't been maintaining commitment
caches then auditing is order the number
of things in the ledger here we have a
ledger with a hundred thousand entries
it takes about 3.5 seconds to audit that
still not so bad really and it's pretty
linear so you could imagine well if you
had a million entries it would be ten
times that it would be about 30 seconds
still you know pretty reasonable
actually a question some people ask is
well
do we have to maintain this ledger
forever you know how do you sort of
clean up the ledger you can create a
snapshot of the state in the ledger and
get rid of the past assuming you know
the set of auditing queries that you're
gonna do moving forward we don't
implement this but this should be
possible right so if you wanted to do
one hundred million rows it would work
out to be about an hour so here is a
graph which shows how long it takes to
create and verify transactions in ZK
ledger and this is varying the number of
banks and again we see this is linear
the more banks the more entries per
transaction the more these commitments
the more range proofs quite honestly is
the problem because there's a range of
proof per entry and what we see here is
that with ten banks it's about a second
or 800 milliseconds to create a
transaction which is not unreasonable
again this sort of achieves the you know
the the multiple per second sort of
things we were looking for depending on
the number of banks however it is linear
in the site and the number of
participants in the system so something
like this is not really suitable for you
know a setting like Bitcoin where there
are thousands if not millions of
participants in the system this graph
sort of gives you an idea of you know
how all of that cost breaks down so
these are the components in the proofs
there and again I think the thing to get
from here is that range proofs are the
entirety of the problem so this is the
number in a transaction for K
participants so if you know eat this is
each slot there are two different
commitments the first commitment and
then the auxilary commitment there's two
different consistency proofs there's a
disjunctive proof and there's a range
proof and yeah the the commitment is one
elliptic curve point which Ingo is a big
int to begins
and so that's 64 bytes this is something
that is actually highly compressible we
we didn't actually okay yeah I'll get to
that point
but you note here that the range proofs
are slower and larger than everything
else combined they are the entirety of
the cost of the system so a faster way
of doing range proofs is would really
help a lot it would would make us be
able to handle many many more banks so
this is the cost in a transaction per
participant in the system
one thing that I want to point out is
that we this is all very highly
parallelizable
and like I said we're using goes bigint
construction which is not really very
optimized at all so I think that there
are a lot of opportunities to make this
faster so I think we could we could if
we sort of put in some engineering
legwork we could we could create a
system that was maybe twice as fast as
what we have now and could handle maybe
a hundred banks so really quickly to
wrap up related work if you're
interested in this topic there's a lot
of different papers to read about and
sort of study this is all confidential
assets kind of sort of kicked off this
line of using Peterson commitments for
privacy in cryptocurrencies zero cash
was the origin of using ZK snarks they
don't really support auditing in any
fashion then there's there's a couple
papers that are really interesting one
from Andrew Lowe actually who's in the
economics department here at MIT on
using secure multi-party computation to
attack this problem the the issue with
that sort of design is that it doesn't
actually have the completeness guarantee
that we have so if the ledger really
represents the assets in the system and
the assets that you're trying to audit
then there's no way for a participant to
lie in a multi-party computation they
can use sort of the wrong inputs so
those systems provide secrecy but they
don't provide completeness and then I
mentioned before solidus before which I
think our techniques would apply to
really nicely and then a there's a paper
a design for doing some other sorts of
accountability stuff with crypto
currencies like proving you paid your
taxes or proving that that money didn't
go through some blacklisted thing using
ZK snarks but that that's not really a
system it's a design but I think that's
also a really promising area to consider
so future work we want to consider more
applications besides just you know large
investment banks trading securities and
assets can we do something when
say clinical trials could we do
something with supply chains I think
that these techniques can be applied to
a lot more areas and I'd love to hear
from you guys if you have ideas on that
or if you're interested in working on
that and want to do a UROP or maybe even
an image that's definitely something
that's on the table we get surprisingly
far with Peterson commitments but if we
included more interesting types of
cryptographic primitives we could
probably get more functionality so
what's the type we know given that we
might want to apply this to different
use cases how what types of
functionality might we need there's
someone at the Media Lab here who is
interested in running algorithms on
research trials and secrecy and privacy
is really important how can you know I
haven't even looked at his sort of
machine learning algorithms yet but can
we run machine learning algorithms on
Peterson commitments or do we need
something something else also another
really important area of future work is
to optimize the implementation like I
said I think we could get at least twice
as fast if not more and in conclusion
yeah if you want to work on any of these
things please let me know if you're
interested in using cryptographic
primitives to achieve privacy with
interesting functions let me know the
and this is the website for zk ledger
which at the moment is really just the
paper we have a code base which is too
embarrassing to be released out into the
real world but we'll get there shortly
once we clean it up
so that's it so thanks for listening
hope you found it interesting
[Applause]